a sea of descent flooding minsk
more than 100 000 protesters marched
through the capital
calling for an end to president
alexander lukashenko's nearly three
decades-long rule
this protest cannot be stopped anymore
there's no way back
the point of no return has already been
crossed the people will go to the end to
defend their constitutional rights
the legal system does not function in
our country violence rules our country
one man rules our country
the month-long protest marks the biggest
challenge to lukashenko's grip on power
in what's been called europe's last
dictatorship
the opposition is refused to accept the
result of last month's election
which the president says he won with 80
percent of the vote
speaking from exile in neighboring
lithuania his rival svetlana
tikanovskaya call for new elections
the country's in a state of political
crisis and the only way out of this
crisis
is announcing another transparent and
fair election
has shown no intention of relinquishing
power a visit by the russian prime
minister last week
seemed only to embolden the 66 year old
straw man
he spent the past days warning his
neighbors poland
latvia lithuania and ukraine against
interfering
in belarus internal business rather than
extending an olive branch
authorities have confronted the mostly
peaceful protesters with sticks and tear
gas
and the president has unleashed bans of
brass knuckle security forces on men
women and children local rights groups
say at least 250 people were detained
nationwide on sunday
adding to the thousands arrested since
the protest began
many have returned bruced and battered
with horror stories of humiliation
and outright torture but the latest
protests underlined their determination
to press ahead
with their demands
well these demonstrations in belarus
have now gone on for four
straight weekends and the number of
protesters taking part is increasing too
our correspondent nick connolly is in
minsk and he sent us this assessment
neither the torrential rain nor repeated
government warnings could keep people
off the streets of mints today
coming out as they did in their hundreds
of thousands against one man
alexander lukashenko a month after
belarus rigged election
and these protests just won't go away
instead they're getting bigger
week after week today you saw people out
with their friends
their pets and even their children and
these are the very same people that
alexander lukashenko has called rats
his government defends them as
prostitutes and drug addicts
but when you speak to them you get a
sense they've lost their fear of the
government
and instead they're laughing at it
laughing at a government
that distributes pictures of lukashenko
with an unloaded gun in full military
gear in front of his own palace
but it's not as if they wouldn't have
good reason to be fearful tonight again
playing close policemen
arresting people seemingly are random
and with impunity all across minsk
when you talk to people about their
fears they tell you one thing over and
over again
there are just too many of us they can't
put us all away
you